we begin with a big surprise in
washington on a bill that could affect
americans for generations democratic
senator joe manchin has reversed his
opposition to legislation meant to help
reduce inflation lower prescription drug
costs and fight climate change but
republicans oppose the measure and his
patches is not guaranteed nancy cortes
is at the white house where this bill is
welcome news for president biden nancy
good morning what's on the line here
well vlad simply put this would be the
largest u.s climate change legislation
ever president biden last night declared
it historic it is the product of secret
negotiations over a package that until
yesterday appeared to be dead
two weeks after walking away from a
climate deal west virginia democrat joe
manchin embraced one last night with a
compromise dubbed the inflation
reduction act of 2022. the centerpiece
about 370 billion dollars worth of clean
energy tax incentives and grants
including seventy five hundred dollar
tax credits for many americans who buy
electric cars
the bill would also allow medicare to
negotiate the price of some prescription
drugs and cap out of pocket drug costs
for seniors at two thousand dollars a
year democrats say the cost of all this
would be more than offset by a new
minimum tax on corporations this is a
bill that truly is about fighting
inflation
bringing down costs for families and
putting the country on a sounder
economic footing the motion to concur
with an amendment is agreed to the
surprise deal was announced just hours
after the senate passed a major
bipartisan bill to boost u.s computer
chip production
[Applause]
[Music]
it all comes amid an otherwise gloomy
week of economic news with consumer
confidence down for a third straight
month in the face of record inflation
most families were paying less than two
dollars a gallon at the pump just two
years ago these are not normal times
yesterday the fed hiked short-term
interest rates another three-quarters of
a point in a bid to bring prices back
down as customers and business owners
struggle we are not buying anything
extra we are buying only what we need to
provide the meals that we a lot for it's
the hardest it's ever been to be in
business with every cost going up
and this morning everyone is watching
for the release of the second quarter
gross domestic product numbers typically
if gdp falls for a second quarter in a
row that could signal a looming
recession but the biden administration
has been insisting that that is not the
case this time around that the economy
is simply
recalibrating after a post pandemic boom
nate
nancy thank you